[Applaudissements]
11h du matin dont les cuisines du ch et
vieillards près d'orléans
chacun est à son poste
tout doit être prêt pour le service de
midi et demi au menu aujourd'hui du
potiron rôti au miel avec une autre
halte à qui a vu concombres des tomates
fraîches
ainsi que des des piments sans oublier
quelques feuilles de menthe ciselée pour
parfaire la présentation
[Musique]
avant d'envoyer rancel
petit rôti au miel t'offre état
normal pas tout à fait ce restaurant est
celui d'un ehpad est ici le chef cuisine
chaque jour 180 repas complet parce que
bon moi ça me ferait au nahd bientôt
si ses pensionnaires se régale c'est
parce qu'ici on a délaissé l'industriel
au profit des produits frais et le coup
on a notre fournisseur qui est qui et
surtout re voilà les les produits sont
150 kilomètres à la ronde de tours juste
hâtivement parlant ça rien à voir quoi
travailler des produits frais c'est pas
le même goût c'est enfin voilà quoi c
c'est une évidence
des efforts remarqués par le célèbre
guide gastronomique gault et millau
il récompense régulièrement les
restaurants du groupe qui se démarquent
bon appétit
vous mangez cas vous pouvez mais
l'intéressé très bon multi phy
en tout 68 ehpad ont reçu le prestigieux
label preuve qu'il est possible d'offrir
une cuisine de grande qualité en très
grande quantité
un modèle qu'une loi votée en 2018
généralise dans tous les restaurants
collectifs publics et certains
restaurants privés cette loi a été
imaginée lors des états généraux de
l'alimentation
d'où son nom et galim dans le public
elle impose aux assiettes servies dans
les écoles collèges lycées foot ou
d'autres établissements comme les
hôpitaux un minimum de 50 % de produits
de qualité à l'année
20% de cette assiette doit être dédiée
aux produits bio le reste peut se
répartir sur d'autres labels de qualité
comme les sigles aop oui gp des quotas à
respecter au 1er janvier prochain
autrement dit demain pour les
établissements
sacha ménard il responsable de la
production de la cuisine centrale de
tours bonjour
ça va merci pour sa cuisine a plutôt
misé sur les circuits de proximité pour
remplir les objectifs de la loi c'est à
moins d'une heure de route à betts le
château qu'ils s'approvisionnent en
lente innobio ouais on est sur du 5 5
tonnes est à peu près
environ
la loi et ghalib ne l'obligent pas à
privilégier les producteurs locaux mais
pour sacha ménard c'est une évidence
écologique et économique un point de vue
que partage philippe joubert
converties à l'agriculture biologique
depuis 28 ans encore là on revient
toujours à l'environnement on essaie
d'être plus alors n'est pas parfait mais
on essaie d'être le plus clean possible
et plus on travaille au local vents
déplacent les produits on sait le coup
de faire venir un truc de chine bon
c'est pas forcément le cas pour la
nourriture mais
les lentilles produite avec ce château
qui monte à tour ses 50 km ce serait
bête de faire venir alors on pourrait
les faire venir du pire c'est pas que
mes collègues du pays
mais n'empêche qu'il ya 250 300
kilomètres donc là c'est voilà tout ça
c'est dans le bon sens quoi la cuisine
centrale de tours a presque atteint
l'objectif de 20% de bio sacha ménard
profite de sa visite pour repérer de
nouveaux produits
voient les huiles de tournesol et les
huiles de colza ça peut permettre
d'augmenter notre part de local de bio
et de faire deux produits made in
touraine mais pour espérer retrouver ses
huiles dans sa cuisine
il devra passer par un appel d'offres
obligatoire pour tout marché public
les lentilles de la maison gibert elles
ont le feu vert ils font route vers
tours
la cuisine centrale de tours est la plus
importante de la région centre val de
loire
elle produit huit mille repas par jour
et alimente toutes les écoles de la
ville c'est là que l'on retrouve nos
lentilles
voilà comme à la maison avec le petit
bouquet garni l'eau qui va bien les
oignons du sel du poivre juste le
produit naturel c'est très bien et ça
donc c'est consommer avec les saucisses
de morteau donc la saucisse de morteau
si une sortie ski gp d'avoir les
produits comme ça c'est super agréable
en fait ça fait plaisir voilà sortir de
l'industriel s'est toujours bien
[Musique]
mais tout va de l'ambition la ville
écologiste veut aller plus loin que la
loi et galim elle mise sur une nouvelle
cuisine centrale pour atteindre les 100%
de fruits et légumes bio locaux entre
ressemblera une cuisine avec une grosse
légume briller une unité de production
qui aura une petite unité de production
pour les crèches pour pouvoir isoler et
réalisée 100% des mixes et maisons pour
les bébés et un atelier pâtisserie un
chantier estimé à 10 millions d'euros
pour offrir à l'horizon 2024 une cuisine
modèles tous plus respectueuse de
l'environnement est meilleure pour la
santé des enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sud de la ville c'est l'heure du
déjeuner à l'école jean giraudoux les
lentilles de la maison gibert vont être
servis dans le cadre de la semaine du
goût seront elles justement au bout de
ce jury exigeant
auquel vient ses meilleurs voeux des
lentilles à la cantine ou à la maison
mère la question parce que
que ces habituels à compter de mai à la
maison mange pas trop ça mais là quand
tu me manques pouces montées à chaque
année
les légumineuses ne sont pourtant pas
facile à faire aimer aux enfants
les stars indétrônable de la cantine
reste
mais depuis 2010 9 et l'introduction de
vos repas végétariens une fois par
semaine les choses changent
pour autant la viande n'est pas exclue
de l'évolution en cours dans les
cantines et la restauration collective
nous sommes à 40 km au nord de tours
pascal naudin et agriculteurs il fait
partie des premiers à s'être lancé dans
la production du nouvel viande
labellisée la viande le grand bain ça a
commencé au mois de septembre mais
j'avais trois animaux d'inscrits pour
partir dans le label de grand boeuf en
qu'une bête charolaise qui est parti et
première semaine de septembre et les
deux autres une charolaise et une
limousine parti il ya une dizaine de
jours ce label a été lancé par la
chambre d'agriculture d'indre et loire
pour répondre à la demande croissante en
viande de qualité
donc l'idée avec ce label en fait ça a
été de construire une filière viande
bovine donc éligible à la loi galim donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a construit un label
rouge pour qu'ils puissent en fait être
prioritaires pour rentrer en fait dans
la restauration collective
parce qu'elle n'a eu aucune difficulté à
placer trois de ses bêtes dans le label
son exploitation respecter déjà les
critères de bien-être animal rocky
pour vous ce label est qu'est-ce qui
vous apporte concrètement
la sécurité financière voilà on a d un
meilleur coup que ce qu'on a pu
connaître l'an dernier dans du marché
traditionnel quoi donc oui si ça se
stagné prochaine on est sur les mêmes
prix oui c'est très bien
l'année prochaine en tout cas la demande
sera bien là 3 7 collèges quatre
communes et kateri pas donc pas ses
commandes jusqu'en 2025
une première étape sur le chemin de la
cuisine de demain mais dans tous ses
établissements
il faut aussi apprendre à cuisiner sans
viande
nous sommes au lycée hôtelier d'orléans
donc là tabou les deux saisons
salade de pommes de terre aux algues
lavagne du marché gace sur les bancs de
l'école pas de débutant à la place des
chefs confirmés du personnel de cuisine
fraîche comme toujours les grosses
légumineuses faites tremper minimum 24
heures c'est beaucoup mieux au menu de
leur formation mise à jour des
connaissances pour mieux négocier le
virage végétale en cours dans les
cantines ils ont des connaissances liées
à la viande liés à la hausse hausse les
fonds de sauce en fait avec des des
poudres de beaucoup d'additifs et c'est
donc forcément il faut les remettre dans
je dirais dans une dans des conditions
où ils peuvent avoir des accès à des
produits naturels ça c'est la base en
fait de tout ce que l'on fait
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
pour faux
du coup je la râpe com
petit-bourg ouais d'accord
avec pau avec pau
exercice du jour travailler des produits
bio de a à z
l'exception d'hier est presque devenu la
règle aujourd'hui
il ya une évolution de la cantine la
prestation qui est énorme pour moi tous
et tous ces produits transformés ont ça
comment ça je dis pas que ça disparaît
totalement mais on en voit de moins en
moins parce qu'elle donne aussi à ses
cuisines étudiants des idées de recettes
pour le menu végétarien
obligatoire au moins une fois par
semaine dans les écoles publiques et
privées
suggestions du jour lasagnes aux légumes
et haricots hazuki faire écho aux oublis
c'est ça ce sont des petits haricots des
pierres etc aux japonais et donc ça va
bien en fait complété en fait la
protéine la recette les idées plaisent
mais certains participants s'interrogent
pour vont-ils vraiment les reproduire
dans leur cuisine
le souci de bios etc c'est un petit peu
cher son projet n'est autre chose dr
fodé fall et aussi des moyens derrière
eux des moyens que ça prend plus de
temps va travailler la salade de pommes
de terre j'ai vu que cet effet la pizza
aller au four la lasagne du marché c'est
au four
ça n'a pas forcément un
un surcoût énorme en fait le bio en
restauration collective à partir du
moment où on transforme soi même et puis
aussi lorsque vous avez la lutte contre
le gaspillage alimentaire vous prenez un
poireau on va pas ajouté le verre on va
le garder pour faire un potage donc à
partir du moment où vous arrivez à
comprendre ça et a jeté le moins
possible les bains là vous êtes gagnant
gagnant qualité en goût en maîtrise des
coûts mais aussi humainement pour tous
ceux qui aimeraient police
ça nous donne envie de découvrir d'aller
encore plus loin dans motive à faire
vraiment de
préparation par exemple différ maison du
fait maison on sera content qu'on peut
le faire
avec les moyens qu'on a actuellement au
bout du compte la portée écologique et
sociale de la loi et galim dépendra de
ce que les établissements feront se
contenteront-ils des seuils minimums
fixés dans la loi où iront ils plus loin
se tourneront-ils vers les producteurs
locaux ou bien vers des fournisseurs
étrangers
c'est là toute la question
[Musique]